There's no type of fame quite like the one
actors are thrust into after starring in a
Marvel movie.
With international attention can also come
backlash of equal intensity, and sadly, 7-year-old
Avengers: Endgame actress Lexi Rabe is currently
facing the negative effects of being part
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
"What is wrong with you people?"
People have reportedly begun harassing Rabe,
who plays Morgan Stark, the adorable daughter
of Robert Downey Jr.'s Tony Stark and Gwyneth
Paltrow's Pepper Potts in Avengers: Endgame.
Though no specific incidents of stuff have
been explicitly mentioned, it seems that the
harassers became upset over Rabe's behavior
when they saw her in public, finding fault
with her acting, quote, "silly" and evidently
declining to take photos with them.
Rabe and her mother, Jessica, addressed the
unfortunate situation in a video uploaded
to Rabe's Instagram account.
Jessica Rabe wrote in the caption that, quote,
"yet again Lexi's getting it," and asked
everyone to please withhold their opinions
about her daughter, so that she can, quote,
"grow up in the free world."
In the clip, Lexi is seen apologizing for
not being perfect, reminding people that she's
just a young girl:
"Hi.
I'm Lexi Rabe.
And I'm only seven years old.
And I mess up sometimes."
Jessica Rabe elaborated in the caption:
"She's a normal human being and she's a child.
We give her a talking and we give her timeouts
but we don't do that in public.
Sometimes we're rushing from place to place
stressed like everyone else to get to set
on time or work or whatever and we seem a
little grumpy.
I'm sorry if you see us this way but that's
life!
If you ask us for an autograph we [almost
always] say yes.
If we happen to be having a bad day that might
put us right on the right!
We are not perfect!"
She also noted that, contrary to what some
may believe, Lexi is a well-behaved child,
and if she wasn't, Marvel probably wouldn't
have hired her for Avengers: Endgame.
Rabe's mother then requested that people refrain
from passing judgements or making harsh remarks
until they have children of their own, and
asked that they realize the Rabe family is,
quote, "not perfect" and isn't "claiming to
be."
She ended the caption with a heartwarming
reminder that, quote, "My children love me
and respect me even if they act out sometimes.
Thank you!
Jessica!"
At the end of the video, Lexi, who still had
a smile on her face despite all the backlash,
then tugged on heartstrings when she delivered
the iconic line from Endgame to those who
have supported her:
"Bye.
love you 3,000."
When it was announced earlier this year
that Orange Is the New Black alum Ruby Rose
had landed the role of Batwoman on the small
screen, disgruntled fans raised their proverbial
pitchforks and claimed that she was the wrong
choice for the part.
The Australian actress deleted her Twitter
account when the negativity became overwhelming.
If cruel criticism can push adult actors to
step away from the limelight, it can only
be much, much worse for a young girl like
Rabe who has never been exposed to anger and
animosity like this before.
Thankfully, the Morgan Stark actress seems
to be surrounded by a strong and loving family,
who will keep her spirits high and outside
negativity low.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.